[Music]  hey it's my turn now  give me a second please  uh peter  what's up  i have a visual object heading downtown  along the river  target believed to be alone shoot to  kill  nine six five let's [ __ ] them in  uh  that was you who did that  [Music]  civilian presence  [Music]  out of the way step aside step aside  step aside no one moved  get your weapons down you wait here um  [Music]  yulia can you tell me why you decided to  help the alien  at what point did you start having  feelings for him  do i have to answer they're back again  you you're in danger  you all went too far in your research we  have to get out of here  you can come back  but she must be eliminated so this is a  cyber attack but not from this planet  you know i don't belong here dad  everything's gonna be fine  i don't even have a passport how are we  gonna cross the border we'll have to  cook up a corruption scam  no more cell phones no more digital  [Music]  technology  [Music]  help me  [Music]  [Music]  you